the parts of a coat of arms or heraldic  achievement  the shield  the helm on top the torse or wreath the  crest above the helm  the mantling the supporters  the compartment and the motto the shield  contains the field and the images  depicted on the field are called charges  the term tincture refers to the colors  used in the design there are seven main  tinctures two metals or meaning gold and  argent meaning silver then there are  five colors  ghouls red azure blue  vert green  purpur purple and sable black  furs are tinctures meant to resemble  animal furs worn by noblemen there are  two main furs hermann which mimics the  fur of a weasel and ver which mimics the  fur of a squirrel